[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo vissuto una pandemia stiamo
vivendo una crisi energetica e il futuro
che ci si prospetta davanti a un futuro
con dei problemi sicuri da un punto di
vista ambientale sociale ed economico
bene qualcuno di voi potrà pensare che
Discussione pesante ed Ha pienamente
ragione perché parlare di futuro non è
mai una cosa leggera non è mai una cosa
facile perché ci sono questioni pesanti
questioni complicate ma è anche vero che
noi ci mettiamo di nostro ci mettiamo di
nostro perché abbiamo un racconto di
futuro molto pessimistico quasi direi
hollywoodiano come se noi facessimo
parte di questo film dove alla fine non
finisce mai con un lieto fine dove ci
sono sempre problemi su problemi e un
po' Il nostro atteggiamento nei
confronti del futuro
in più Mettiamoci dentro una parola una
parola che nel tempo è stata svuotata
utilizzata tantissime volte oggi non
sappiamo più che significato ha la
parola sostenibilità bene
sostenibilità mi ricordo che prima della
pandemia aveva un senso un potere un
peso Incredibile tutti noi ci Riempiamo
la bocca di slogan di cambiamento di
voler modificare il mondo il futuro di
voler modificare noi stessi di voler
cambiare il nostro il nostro futuro il
nostro modo di consumare il nostro modo
di essere consapevoli bene Ci è bastato
un anno quest'anno un anno di crisi vera
che ha cambiato un po' le nostre vite
che a me sta a repentaglio il nostro
benessere perché di questo stiamo
parlando per mandare completamente a
gambe all'aria la nostra idea di
sostenibilità
oggi parlare di sostenibilità e parlare
di tutto e parlare di niente
bene
fare questa introduzione dice un po'
scomoda però
se ci tengo a farla perché molte volte
la base della discussione sul futuro e
sulla sostenibilità oggi vorrei
raccontarvi una storia in grado di
potervi dare un'altra visione di futuro
è un significato più preciso di
sostenibilità in questo caso vi
racconterò la mia storia la storia di
una scoperta Io mi chiamo Lorenzo
cannella ho 32 anni e sono uno
scienziato del mare e da qualche anno
faccio l'imprenditore agricolo
la storia incomincia quindici anni fa
quando ho cominciato l'università ho
studiato il mare e all'epoca già si
incominciava tantissimo A parlare si
parlava tantissimo di cambiamento
climatico e l'impatto dei mari che il
pesce in mare stia finendo degli
inquinanti e contaminanti e la plastica
di problemi su problemi e noi come
generazione capiamo di quanto potevamo
essere importanti quanto
quell'università quelle università
potevano essere importanti per
prepararci per il futuro per la sfida
del domani bene nonostante volessimo
essere tu volessimo dare un contributo
al futuro non riuscivamo bene a capire
noi in che posizione stare nei confronti
del futuro e del presente ci sentiamo un
po' disorientati e non riusciamo a
capire come poter essere determinanti
In quegli anni ho approfondito la
tematica del Come poter produrre più
cibo in maniera sostenibile perché
dovete sapere che da qua ai prossimi
anni continueremo a crescere sempre di
più a livello di popolazione mondiale e
ci sarà sempre più bisogno di cibo e ci
sarà sempre più bisogno di risorse Il
problema è che le risorse non sono
infinite Anzi sono le stesse che abbiamo
oggi quindi dobbiamo imparare a produrre
meglio e di più
io nella fattispecie ho approfondito la
parte della produzione ittica Quindi
come possiamo allevare del pesce in
maniera più sostenibile allora
Immagino che
tutti voi conosciate Che cos'è questo un
pesce rosso un acquario ognuno di voi
forse l'ha avuto a casa conosceva un
amico come funziona far crescere un
pesce rosso molto semplice semplicemente
diamo del mangime al nostro pesce e
tutti i giorni lui andrà a crescere in
cambio ogni giorno lui ci Regalerà due
cose la sua crescita e della sostanza
organica cacca per capirci vuole essere
chiari bene Per far sì che il pesce
cresca nelle migliori condizioni
possibile Noi tutti i giorni dovremmo
andare a cambiare una parte dell'acqua
che facciamo prendiamo quest'acqua la
andiamo a buttare nel nello scarico del
lavandino facilissimo bene ora
immaginatevi di avere un delle vasche
che sono grandi cento volte 200 volte
più grandi di questa Acquario e
all'interno di queste vasche non abbiamo
più un pesce rosso ma abbiamo un pesce
edibile quindi un pesce che si può
mangiare come funziona a lavare un pesce
alla stessa maniera diamo del mangime il
pesce cresce e ci regala tanta sostanza
organica il problema che ora non
possiamo prendere quest'acqua e buttarla
nello scarico del lavandino che ne
facciamo idea
buttiamola in ambiente impatto
ambientale
bene Un giorno qualcuno gli venne
un'idea perché non utilizziamo
quest'acqua per darla alle piante Ora
qualcuno di voi Starà pensando bella
idea andiamo a recarci i campi Diciamo
che le piante si possono essere
coltivate in tante maniere una di queste
maniere è poter coltivare le piante in
acqua ovvero Le piante possono andare a
galleggiare in acqua attraverso delle
piattaforme ed essere in contatto
diretto con l'acqua attraverso le radici
quindi le radici vengono immerse in
acqua assorbono i nutrienti e l'acqua di
cui hanno bisogno e le piante vanno a
crescere ora
fermi un secondo noi sappiamo che da una
parte abbiamo una vasca con i nostri
pesci che cresce e ci regala tanta
sostanza organica dall'altra abbiamo una
vasca con delle piante che per crescere
hanno bisogno di nutrienti
incominciamo a vedere un collegamento
Però manca qualcosa
La parte fondamentale che manca la fanno
loro
i batteri l'organismo più antica al
mondo ci permette di trasformare
qualcosa che è uno scarto un rifiuto che
potenzialmente può impattare l'ambiente
in qualcos'altro riesce a trasformare un
altro prodotto che in questo caso può
diventare fertilizzante naturale
ora
ricapitoliamo la questione abbiamo i
pesci crescono mangime ci danno sostanze
organica prendiamo quest'acqua e la
diamo in un'altra vasca i batteri che la
trasformano per essere utilizzata come
nutriente veniamo quest'acqua che acqua
e nutriente la diamo in un'altra vasca
dove ci sono le piante che assorbono i
nutrienti e crescono andando a Depurare
l'acqua alla fine di questo ne potremmo
prendere l'acqua delle piante
riutilizzarla nuovamente per il circuito
Vi ho appena spiegato un sistema di
produzione chiuso ovvero dove le materie
girano all'interno un sistema che si
chiama acquaponica
noi all'interno di questo sistema non
solo possiamo andare a riutilizzare le
materie ma stiamo andando a ricreare un
ecosistema naturale non ci stiamo
inventando qualcosa Stiamo andando
semplicemente a imitare la natura perché
abbiamo messo insieme degli organismi
che vanno a lavorare insieme
e questo sistema ci consente di andare a
ridurre l'utilizzo di acqua perché
andiamo a usarle in maniera efficiente
andiamo a riciclare a riutilizzare la
sostanza organica che è impattante in
qualcosa di diverso in fertilizzante e
in più come già detto prima siamo delle
vasche quindi siamo fuori dalla terra
Questo significa che noi non impattiamo
la terra e la terra non impatta noi
perché purtroppo oggi in molti terreni
dove andiamo a produrre cibo sono
inquinati
e la cosa più incredibile dato che siamo
fuori dalla terra che possiamo andare a
realizzare questo impianto in campagna
all'interno di una serra Come possiamo
andare a realizzare in città anche
all'interno di questa sala L'unica cosa
che manca è la luce ci andiamo a mettere
i LED
bene a me questa scoperta cambio
completamente la mia visione di vedere
le cose la mia visione di incominciare a
vedere queste come un sistema perché non
so L'avevo trovato una miniera
efficiente e sostenibile per poter
produrre del cibo Ma potevo anche andare
a ad aggiungere un pezzo che mancava al
mio puzzle quel pezzo che mi non
riuscivo a trasformare le belle idee di
sostenibilità in azioni in maniera
concreta attraverso questo Ero riuscito
a trasformare delle belle idee in
qualcosa di concreto
ma non basta chiaramente non basta mai
la cosa che che manca è comprovare che
questa bella idea funziona perché dalle
nostre parti se le cose non funzionano
non servono
bene e fu allora che penso presi la
decisione più coraggiosa della mia vita
Io all'epoca mi trovo all'estero
decisi di
incominciare di fare un'impresa e
ritornare a casa per farla ora metto un
secondo in pausa questo racconto e
analizziamo la cosa Io ho 32 anni
appartengo a una generazione che è nata
con le valigie in mano con l'idea di
esplorare il mondo per imparare e per
restarci non per tornare e non vuole
tornare perché casa non gli piace non
vuole non vuole tornare perché ci sono
dei motivi perché a casa ci sentiamo
all'interno di un fuoco incrociato dove
Da una parte ci sentiamo dire quando
siamo nati che saremo precari che saremo
disoccupati che il nostro futuro è pieno
di difficoltà e dall'altra ci sentiamo
dire voi domani
sistemerete il futuro voi domani Avrete
le competenze per poter riparare quello
che abbiamo fatto
un po' di pressione giusto un po'
però
La cosa che mi fece scattare la voglia
di fare fu che me era un po' stufato che
ogni volta che guardavo online progetti
incredibili le cose più belle e
futuristiche Diciamo erano sempre fatte
all'altra parte del mondo sempre fatte
in Australia sempre fatte a nord Europa
sempre fatte in America Perché non
possiamo fare qualcosa del genere a casa
nostra Perché no
e soprattutto io che scusa avevo per non
provarci
e fu allora che qualche anno fa decide
di tornare a casa per fare l'impresa
ora ci tengo a sottolineare perché qua
andiamo a comprovare questa cosa può
funzionare che l'acquaponica può
funzionare non solamente da un punto di
vista numerico come vuole l'impresa ma
da un punto di vista proprio romantico
della parola impresa perché per
lanciarsi in un'avventura del genere Ci
vuole coraggio e ci vuole voglia perché
ci vogliono compagni di viaggio perché
il percorso sarà pieno di ostacoli sarà
complicato ma è un percorso che oggi
dobbiamo fare perché dobbiamo comprovare
non solo che possiamo produrre in questo
caso Shiba in maniera diversa ma perché
serve di più serve avere il coraggio di
portare educazione avere il coraggio di
portare cultura cultura per capire che
oggi è necessario spiegare come possiamo
produrre cibo Quante risorse servono che
impatto possono avere per essere più
consapevoli per dire la verità noi
stessi
e soprattutto bisogna portare cultura
anche sotto altri punti di vista la
cultura dell'essere inclusivi inclusivi
anche nei confronti di persone che sono
sia normodotate che hanno sia disabilità
perché bisogna ricominciare a ridare
dignità all'uomo e non per ultimo
inclusione nei confronti dei giovani nei
confronti di quei giovani a quella lì
appartengo che sono disorientati che
sono confusi che non sanno cosa
aspettarsi dal futuro bisogna raccontare
belle storie bisogna raccontare storie
che possono trasformarsi in realtà
alla fine di questa alla fine di questo
di questa storia
Che cos'è la sostenibilità
bene Io penso che la sostenibilità sia
un'eredità si un patrimonio che lasciamo
alle future generazioni Non solo perché
cioè sostenibilità sia chiaro Non è è
riutilizzare sostanze e andare a
risparmiare acqua e un processo
innovativo ma è qualcosa di più la
sostenibilità sostenibilità è un è un
modo di pensare è un modo di pensare
nuovo perché dobbiamo capire che il
mondo al quale viviamo è un mondo
Complesso dove non possiamo più agire da
individui dobbiamo incominciare agire da
ecosistema un ecosistema che è in grado
di essere inclusivo sostenibile e
multidisciplinare
e soprattutto questa complessità non
dobbiamo averne paura non dobbiamo aver
paura complessiva significa biodiversità
essere diversi e non riuscire a capirci
non dobbiamo averne paura dobbiamo
spiegarla dobbiamo chiarirla raccontarla
perché se noi andiamo a spiegare a un
adulto a un ragazzo o un bambino come
funziona la natura e come può come
cresce una pianta un pesce andiamo a
raccontare in primis la complessità e la
bellezza la biodiversità della natura e
andiamo anche a spiegare perché dobbiamo
proteggerla perché dobbiamo gestirla in
maniera diversa e in più se spieghiamo
questo gli possiamo anche spiegare come
possiamo allevare e coltivare un pesce
una pianta che lo possiamo fare in modo
sostenibile e che uno di questi modi
sostenibili si chiama acquaponica e che
l'acquaponica ci permette di andare a
levare e coltivare un pesce una pianta
in campagna come in città
ora immaginate di mettere tutte queste
informazioni all'interno del più potente
computer che abbiamo sulla terra che il
nostro cervello bene il nostro cervello
andrà elaborare in un anno in cinque
anni in 10 anni tutte queste
informazioni e andrà ad avere una
visione di futuro fatta di belle storie
fatta di ottimismo fatta di idee e di
soluzioni che saranno in grado di
affrontare non più i problemi ma le
sfide del futuro grazie
[Applauso]